- Hey man I was thinking maybe
we should like hangout sometime.
Grab a beer, a brew,
engineer something together,
have a picnic, do sports.
No, that's stupid.
Okay. Whatever I got this.
Wish me luck.
- Five tips to a more productive day.
Number 1: Listening to
music that's where you zone
and sends a message to
coworkers that you are not
to be bothered.
Okay. I could do this.
- So, it's just a friendly
softball tournament
so there's nothing really riding on it.
But I still think we need
to come in first place.
- Girl, I am comfortable with that.
- Harper and Kaylen are in.
Oh, and Charlie played
baseball in college.
- Oh, how do you know that?
- His wife's Facebook.
- Oh...
- He dosen't have a personal Facebook
so sometimes I go there for updates.
- So, we should ask
him to play then right?
- That is a great idea, Anna.
I was just going to ask him to coach me.
- You mean coach the team?
- You are full of ideas today.
- Number 2: Learn how to say no.
It's all about setting
boundaries and prioritizing.
Prioritizing isn't a word, dude.
- Charlie, we were setting
up a softball league.
- We want you to play short stop?
- No.
- But what if we offered you...
- I hear what you're saying,
and I'm going to veto it.
- No.
- Please do this for us?
- I know I will write Charlie
an email leave a paper trail.
Everything should have a paper trail.
Dear Charlie, Bromance?
Hope all is well.
Best, Elliot.
Send.
Now we wait.
- Number 3: Only check
emails at the end of the day.
You only got to tell me twice.
Allright.
- Elliot, we're starting
a softball league.
- You're the short stop.
- But doesn't Charlie play short stop?
- Not anymore.
- I can't play short stop.
- Thanks for cooperating.
- I can play team mom.
- Number 4: Drink more water.
You got it.
- Hey man you gonna get coffee or ...
- No.
- Cool. I hate coffee.
See ya bro.
You were right, Mr Harris.
I don't deserve something
as special as a bromance.
- Elliot, my man, I
meant to ask you earlier
are you busy this weekend?
- The weekend ... never.
- Perfect. Do you want to grab a beer?
- I would love to have a picnic with you
- Picnic?
Okay, yeah, you know what screw it.
Let's do a picnic.
We'll talk about it later.
I got to run to the bathroom.
I've been drinking water all day
so like bladder ...
- Yeah. totally.
- All right man.
- Yes.
- [Anna] Come on you can do it.
You're doing it.
- [Elliot] I usually
cry when I play sports.
- [ Anna] All right thank you very much.
See you on the field.